- Instead of jockeying and
politicking and pondering
and posturing and debating
for three to four months,
we're just in do mode now
and when you're in do mode,
you fucking get shit done.
(deep inhale)
(thumping beat)
Yup, 10 o'clock?
See you then, bye bye.
Episode nine of Dailyvee was just posted.
And episode 10 is in action.
It's so early and in influencer marketing,
I think most people are undereducated
and would go the route of impressions
and so I think they
would go to a DJ Khaled
or somebody that looked like me and say
how many views are you
getting on your story
and then they would
apply a CPM against that
and that would be that.
And that would be a grave
mistake of not understanding
the difference of values
of a Twitter impression
versus a Snapchat impression
versus an Instagram impression.
What gets me excited
about Snapchat and why
I'm excited about it is
I think people actually
consuming those impressions.
When I have 25,000 views
on my stories on Snapchat,
I no question believe that
it is more valuable than the
225,000 followers I have on Instagram that
potentially see it, right,
or Twitter or Facebook so,
I day trade attention, right.
That's what I do for a living.
I reverse engineer attention.
My belief is that Snapchat
and Instagram right now
are the two kings and queens of attention.
(truck engine roaring)
Gonna go straight, gonna
make a left, go straight,
but we're making a left into
this big building right here.
- [Voiceover] Over here?
- [Gary] Uh-huh.
If it's available.
And let me know.
Thanks, let me know what my options are.
Thanks, bye bye.
(elevator dings)
- [Voiceover] You're early.
- [Gary] I'm gonna come back.
I have to leave, I just
had 30 minutes to kill
and better kill with you guys than.
Hey guys, hi, how are ya?
- [Woman] Good
- [Gary] Good to see ya.
Awesome, hey how are ya?
I think we should really have signs
on the bottom of the front doors where we
walk in consistently.
I think we had like the
great wall there for a while?
I think you should pick
two, like I think there's,
hey Willy, I don't think
there's a single better spot.
I think you would sell a
lot more wine from that
spot than the pillars.
- [Brandon] Okay.
- I think you should
consistently sign that.
- [Voiceover] Would you
(bleeping) subscribe?
And on this channel you're
gonna get my two core shows.
The #AskGaryVee show!
And DailyVee, we're puttin' out real fire.
Shit is intense, and if
you subscribe right now,
subscribe now, you're gonna
make me so goddamn happy.
So email me at gary@vaynermedia.
- What's up?
- What's going on, how are you?
- Good man, how are you?
- [Man] Good.
(woman speaking)
Yeah when something sells out,
eliminates from the site.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- Yup.
(laughs)
Did you think that was,
why was that funny to you?
Why was that funny to you?
- [Brandon] It was just funny.
- That I like say something Wine Library?
Yeah.
- [Voiceover] Hey guys, I'm Gary Vee
- [Voiceover] Hey!
- [Gary] Hello!
- [Voiceover] Hi, Gary!
- How are you?
- God!
- Good to see ya, how are you?
- So good to see you
- [Gary] Good to see you too
All good? How's family?
- [Woman] You look younger.
- I know, I'm getting, taking
care of my health, it helps.
- Oh congratulations.
- [Gary] Thanks a lot,
how are you?
- Good how you doin'?
- Really good, what's cookin'?
- Not much, how 'bout yourself?
Where's your Dad? (laughs)
- (laughs) He's coming back
soon, he's back today, right.
- [Man] Is he back today?
- I think he lands today.
- [Man] Okay.
- I just love talking operations,
Wine Library operations.
It's kind of like riding a
bike, you know, since it's
my family business, it's
kind of like a first love,
it's kind of like, you know,
that meeting with Mitch,
talking about where we're
going and how we wanna
strategize from the financial
standpoint for the business is
kind of like having coffee with
your high school sweetheart
when you're in your 40s or
50s, it's been a long time and
you're out of touch and you
don't know all the context
but there's still that feeling
and clearly when I get into
that mindset it's really just
like riding a bike, it's just
I'm right back in it, even
though at this point my Dad
and Brandon, they're running the business,
it's not hard for me to
calibrate and attack the
business situation at hand.
Are you sick, Eric?
Jesus shit.
Alright listen, honestly like,
because we had a pre-talk
for like five seconds and
everybody here is wicked smart
and sharp and fast as fuck,
is there anything that,
what do I need to know so
I can get you back to rest?
Yup, yup.
I didn't focus on youtube
for almost all my career
until this character
got along and so like,
literally Youtube's been a
focus of mine for a year.
No ,eighteen months.
What was our following
count we started with?
Like we did that other
day, like 30,000, 35,000
now we're at a buck 25, 115?
- [DRock] 115, 120.
- I mean think about that, you know,
eight years to get to 35 and
one year to get 100,000 more.
- [DRock] 144.
- Love it, it's going fast.
One of the biggest secrets in business is
when you have clients
to remind yourself that
they're the customer and they're right.
You could fire them, but while
you have them they're right.
(laughs)
- [Voiceover] He's in trouble?
- Yes he is.
(laughing)
- [Voiceover] You're good.
- [Gary] We gotta get DRock, no worries.
It's unbelievable how
much I hate the Patriots.
- Yeah, I really don't like them either.
That was pretty good
that the Broncos held,
it looked like they were
gonna implode at the end
- Oh the respect level
I have for the Patriots
though is insane, like, I'm always like
they're gonna win, they're gonna win.
- Yeah, I know.
- We're gonna do it here?
You know, I finally articulated
what I do for a living
and I can deploy it now here
for the first time in a meeting
instead of the interview
where it popped up.
I day trade attention.
- [Woman] Mhm.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- I day trade attention,
cause it's not like
Vayner's market in the
year that you live in
and I keep like looking at it
for the last like six months
and I'm like fuck, we're
doing it faster than that.
It's not year, we don't
make a 2016 plan like,
I decided on December
23rd that Snapchat became
very important and then
like it just did like,
it's day trading.
So here's where I'm about to
go, so I fully agree with that,
let me throw you one that
I think is very winnable,
and can be completely game changing.
What a monthly (bleep) for the brand?
- [Voiceover] Oh yes.
- [Gary] Starting right away.
Meaning, I'm standing, which
means, you know DRock.
(woman laughing)
So I think you're so fucking
right and when I think about
and I do think it needs a
website but I debate, yeah.
- [Voiceover] That's
why I didn't really say
- Especially, but I'd
rather, if I had my way,
I'd rather save a 100,000
dollars or 50,000 dollars
more on the website, whatever
that meant, you know,
depth, creative, whatever it meant.
Literally, literally, literally.
And it's like how PR works, right,
it's what I'm doing here with DRock.
I'm not gonna ask.
When I asked to be on
Inc. or Business Insider
or in like Fast Company, you're asking.
Now I produce content, I
post it, they're asking me
to distribute it on their channel.
- I'll tell you why this is genius.
- Thank you.
Just end with that, we're outta here.
(group laughing)
All on digital (bleep), how do I get it?
And get me the 411 and then I'll follow up
and be the bad cop.
- [Steve] Okay you got it
- [Gary] Alright
- [Steve] Yup, thanks.
- [Voiceover] I bought wine from there.
- [Gary] Yeah?
Yeah, we have the best prices.
- [Voiceover] I'm telling you it's
- I'm aware it's the best prices.
Best prices, you have
to come off more often.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, and it's yours?
- Yeah.
- [Voiceover] Okay then.
- Hello my friend.
Good man, sorry to hear about your Dad,
how you doin'?
Keep me updated if anything.
Yeah, keep me updating
if anything gets bad.
Hopefully, of course, of
course, there's nothing.
And don't worry we'll do more,
I wanna actually give you
a preview so you know what
you're walking into today.
So.
Real pleasure, thank
you, have a great day.
Hey, Seth.
- [Voiceover] How are you?
- [Gary] Hey, how are you
gentlemen, good to see ya
- Good to see you, how's everything?
- How's everything?
Everything's super well guys,
good to see you guys
- [Man] I didn't even see ya
- I know I'm hiding!
Good to see ya, good to see ya Seth.
(elevator dings)
Hey, how are ya, really
well brother. How are you?
Alright. Let's do this.
So I think uh, I think for everybody
on the call I think this is grounded in,
growing the revenue of this company.
This company obviously
has different uniqueness
because its bricks and mortar and retail,
different than a pure play
e-com play and number two,
it's in a outstandingly
regulated industry,
and we're like any other
company that we deal with,
we have a lot of our own legacies.
You know, John K, when did we
start working together, 1999?
When you were at Red Hat
or whatever it's called?
- [Voiceover] Uh, '98 I think.
- [Gary] Yeah so, John and I
have basically been working on
Winelibrary.com since 1998.
Brandon's been here
since that timeframe too,
'99 what have you and so,
we have a ton of legacy stuff.
And there's a lot that needs to be done
and we're seeing it already
even with little old
two seconds into affiliate
marketing which is
by the way, from everything I've gathered,
of the 50 million dollar
revenue that wine.com does,
more than half comes from
affiliate sales, right,
so there's much we can do here.
We have the one thing down which is,
we have multiple things down.
We have one core thing down.
We actually have one of the five or seven
best wine shops in America.
Like from a selection
and price standpoint,
we actually have that. That's exciting.
Number two, we have Brian who we,
actually we should probably
go around introduce ourselves
Brian, and John who's on the phone who are
long tenured real family of this company,
developers who are in-house who
after we decide what
we do here we'll add on
or not add-on or whatever are just capable
of just bringing so much more to the table
because they care more
and they're capable.
So we have all the pieces
in place to do great stuff,
I think it's just time to do it.
I'm gonna go counter cultural
and go old school phone sales
and email and texting.
I'm gonna thank you
economy the whole business,
I'm gonna go one-on-one
with every individual person
that's ever bought anything
in this company ever.
So that's where I want
all the energy to go.
So like, all the 4%
margin that you bring me
on affiliate or nine or six or 12,
every one of those
dollars is gonna go into
Rick at 70,000 dollars a year with
all my investment on these guys to build
unbelievable admin tools
that make them the best
human salespeople so instead
of these guys worrying about
- [Voiceover] Moving data.
- Correct, moving fucking data,
and by the way, the thing
that they don't worry about,
that's really on my head,
the company's not worried
about at all which is bestpractices.com.
Like landing page, and
like, fucking affiliate.
We fix all that, all that
can go into something
that I know that I uniquely
can do in the industry
that most people can't,
which is build backend
data tools that make
people sell a lot of wine.
Now that we have the man and woman power
of VaynerMedia to help this,
I would never ask John
or Brandon to do this,
because I'm the most practical
operator of all time,
I'm not gonna ask my people
to do things they can't do,
or are not as the high use of their time,
I think it would be super
fascinating to understand
the inefficiency of all the
hours that go back and forth
in these missing items
versus the vig on my FedEx
shipping charges to see if
like, because if we just
start shipping this and
not going back and forth
communicating in all these admins,
and customers are getting
four bottles and then
the eight come later,
there's a big financial loss,
we don't pay the people that
actually have to play with this
a whole lot like in
comparison to what I think,
but the more as I come in with fresh eyes,
I'm curious to see what the vig is.
For example, if you said
it was a net loss of
35,000 dollars a year, I
would do that for customers
just getting product way faster.
So I need the math. Got it Pam?
- Mhm.
- John, you understood that rant, right,
we're gonna try to figure that out.
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- And by the way when I say we,
that just means that you
and Brandon and Brian
and Brian Delatore just
have to be communicating
to Pam when she asks the
question because whether
it's Pam or somebody else
they'll be coming in here to like
try to collect enough data
- [Voiceover] We have to look at the
numbers to see if it makes sense
- What I'm doing right now
is one, reeducating myself,
two, clearly putting
shit in your guys heads,
so that I don't wanna be
in the next 17 meetings,
I want you guys to take over so.
And when I say you guys I
mean the collective team here.
Like, there's fucking 50 years
of IP in these guys heads
that have to be regurgitated,
they're disadvantage,
is my disadvantage, which is
they're accepting everything
that has been for the
last 10 years so that's.
Every time we've dealt
with stuff, you know,
one bottle we would take it off the site.
We never debated partial ship.
Cause I, not them, created
certain rules for life.
That being one of them,
that's where you guys have
an advantage over them,
that collective friction
is what needs to come out of this.
- So this conversation was around like
operationally how do we
handle this stuff so,
we do wanna talk about
the marketing side of it.
The marketing calendar,
the things that you said
that well we control it,
right, we put the email out,
stuff like that.
I need to understand that
a little bit better about
- [Gary] Let's do it, I'll
tell you everything. Let's go.
- How does that process work,
is there a marketing calendar
do you work on a month ahead
to say that this is what
we will promoting, or it
might be an inventory issue
and you're trying to get rid
of and turn it into cash.
All (laughs) all of those things.
- [Gary] Yes, all runs through Brandon.
And the answer is yes,
email is the backbone
of this business.
- [Man] Okay.
- [Gary] We massively, like
on of the things that I think,
so a couple years ago, I poked my head in
three or four years ago
and I was like fuck,
our email promotions are not as strong,
so I leveled up an email
promotion it was called
the Takeover.
You'd go to winelibrary.com
and it would fuckin',
the shit I complain about,
you know it would take over
the whole site and it would
lead up to this big event
and we would sell a lot.
And then 18 months ago
or so or 12 months ago,
I was like let's do one
of those every week.
Every week there'd be one big item and
it did well and it still
does well and it's still
the big thing but when
we went to the redesign
we never did a takeover,
like a full like now
it's just like a story,
on our website so,
I'm excited to see how
Shopify's UI upfront works
because the thought of like
promoting to the big wine
offering a week in
advance is very powerful,
we would plan very aggressively for that,
even eight to 12 weeks
out cause they'd be very
high margin items.
A lot of what Brandon would
decide would be 24 hours
in advance based on inventories
and based on his buying,
So the promotion calendar
would at best be a week
ahead of time, at worst be morning of.
It depends on how you
wanna look at that one,
so for me as an outsider on that one
I like it cause it's day trading.
Like we're making the smartest decision,
what he's definitely capable of,
when he doesn't overthink it is
making the best decision for that day.
- Different types of affiliates,
eight to 10 different types
of affiliates right so,
certain types you have
to keep on feeding them,
they love it when you are
giving them this kind of
I'll call them flash sales, right?
You're making the decision that day
- [Gary] Just take a step back
our ability to reverse it,
like this is the first
I'm hearing of this like,
our ability to feed
everybody from RetailMeNot to
winey wine wine, you tell
us who the eight are,
and what they need to be
the best is a piece of cake.
Our ability to feed them 52 offers
is much higher than you could ever imagine
cause that's something we've got down.
We just have to know what the rules are
I mean hire somebody to
create more infrastructure
but that's not hard.
This is where being like a
great wine store is gonna
really help like, if it
needs to be product specific,
like was 70 now 20 for
RetailMeNot only people,
we can fuckin' feed that animal all day.
- [Voiceover] Okay, uh yeah I mean,
- I assume that's what
you're referring to 'cause,
the way I think about
affiliate is 20% off any order.
You know five buy one get one free,
but if you're talking about feeding, like
- [Voiceover] That's
literally level one, so
- God bless, tell me,
I'll give you level nine.
That part we can crush.
i really wanna build something
like I want your loyalty
and all these great years
like my big thing right now
is for five or six of you, like,
it's driving me more than anything.
For five or six of you
to have the hyper growth
that you felt underneath
me from being a kid that
sat on safe to being like right?
I wanna replicate that
for the five or six of you
over the next three to five years.
Like you and I what we
just did for five minutes
is better for business.
- [Voiceover] I like that.
And that's what I'm good for.
- So what I want you to do is
an hour a day instead
ops which is important,
you auditing your order
department or your pullers
operations where Brandon needs help there,
I want you to become that guy for him.
Let's find people that can
become the next you and Jeff
and Yaz and Kevin, you know what I mean?
And Eric O. It's how we built it.
- [Voiceover] I'm in.
- [Gary] Okay.
- Good stuff right?
- [Employee] Yup
- [Gary] Good talk,
right? You feel pumped.
- Yeah.
(thumping ukulele rhythm)
- What is this episode what?
- [Brittany] 177.
- [DRock] I don't know.
- 177?
- [Brittany] Yeah.
- [Gary] 177? Alright, let's do it.
Hey everybody this is Gary Vay-Ner-Chuck
and this is episode 177 of the
#AskGaryVee Show!
Snapchat.
Wine Library, the legit
wine palace of the world.
Who's that good looking guy?
Holy crap that dude's amazing.
You are handsome.
How are ya?
Good man, how are you?
Good.
I don't care, like,
meaning like the answer is
that's the right question
and we should talk to them but,
it's not (bleep) knock,
Brandon first of all,
like we've been doing this a long time,
it's not like (bleep)
that's the stupidest shit
I've ever heard in my life.
Like we're fucking good,
that's why I'm not scared,
if we were shit I'd
wanna stage everything.
Is everybody trying to keep
up with the energy here?
- Have a good one.
Have a safe trip.
- Thank you. Take care
of yourself, thank you.
So today was a really interesting day,
really got into the trenches operationally
and on the e-com level at WineLibrary.com
and Wine Library. Lot of fun.
Really got to speak with a
bunch of key executives.
People that have been
with me for a decade, really
talking about the future,
obviously it's such a different
dynamic 'cause I'm not there
day to day anymore and
so it's interesting the
relationship I have with them
because they're my homies
they were there with me
but I'm not there every day
to reinforce, remind, create
that consistent narrative
that I am for VaynerMedia
for example where I'm
operating but it's amazing
to see the trust and the
relationship, really
enjoyed having some of the
VaynerMedia people at
Wine Library bringing their
expertises to the conversation.
Just very excited about
the family wine business
for the next decade.
Lot of fun to interact, spent
a lot of time talking to
finance and Mitch and those kinda things,
spoke to Brian Delatore and
Jeff DeRose operationally
for both Wine Library the
store and WineLibrary,com
spending time with Brandon,
John K. and Brian Ruley
from development, Brandon
who runs kinda the show
along with my dad so.
Just an incredible day. Fun to
like schlep to Newark Airport
Jersey airport that I used for
my entire life until I moved
to Manhattan and so just
a good solid, meaty day
I think that DRock and I found
our cadence in episode nine
about really pushing the
envelope to bring more access
from the meetings, really
spending an extra day or two
editing, getting approvals.
Seeing the reaction from
all of you on episode nine
got us fired up and I think
given that it was Wine Library
where I'm a client and
a person on the show,
I think we'll be able
to bring a lot more meat
in this episode, I hope you
edited it proper, DRock
and I just love all of you guys so much.
Thank you so much for supporting DailyVee.
Getting to go to Jersey for
one of our biggest, oldest
clients was a lot of fun,
new project we're working on,
can't go a whole lot into it but,
what I can say is that when
you align yourself with
very smart executives
from the clients side,
there's nothing more powerful.
I was blown away, I
haven't interacted with
my contemporary, my partner
on the other side on this
brand before and she was
just so massively impressive.
When you align on religion you can go fast
and speed is such a
bigger aspect of business
than people realize and
so instead of jockeying
and politicking and
pondering and posturing,
and debating for three
to four months we're just
in do mode now and when you're in do mode
you fuckin' get shit done.
You like that?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- [Gary] The do mode?
- [DRock] When you're in do mode
- You get shit done.
What's up man?
I think I'm gonna lose you.
- [DRock] And I need my mic.
- Premiere in TSA checkpoint three.
(sneezes)
- (sneezes) Thank you.
- [DRock] I'll leave that in.
- What's that?
- [DRock] I'll leave that in for you.
- I know you're gonna leave
that, you see you know me
so well already, just
leave real shit, DRock.
I think I should give you the mic.
(melodic indie music)